it's got a lot going for this game but
it's like I said performance has gone
awful
for the most part I I was fighting the
last boss
it crashed two or three times wow
series X right yeah series X but I've
been told it's just as bad everywhere
else you know I think we're getting to
the point where these devs are being too
comfortable releasing games that have
too many issues like and I'm I'm to the
point now where it's like Playstation
Xbox Nintendo steam like if these games
don't consistently work in this mad
performance issues rip these games off
your stores
are you gonna rip it off a game pass you
know let's let's talk about no it
doesn't matter if the PC pass it should
work PC games has been like bad bro I
don't game over on the master race
though but you would think like no like